Speaker 1: All right. There are other people
running for the 2024 Republican nomination.
One of those people is Nikki Haley. Nikki
Haley had an event. She spoke at an event.
And it was embarrassing. It was low energy
rivaling Jeb Bush in 2016. It makes Jeb Bush look
electric from 2016 and the event seems totally
brain dead. And Nikki Haley's campaign continues
to remain dead on arrival. This was the SBA List
HQ event in Virginia, and I think that means Small
Business Association list headquarters. She, for
some reason to the SBA, spoke about abortion.
I don't know what's worse, the level of energy
or the arguments that Nikki Haley is making.
Speaker 4: The next president must find a
national consensus. That might sound strange
to many people. Under Roe, consensus was replaced
by demonization. And let's be honest, most in the
media prioritize demonization. They stoke division
putting pitting Americans against each other.
No one talks about finding consensus. Everyone
goes to the barricades and attacks the other side.
They've turned a sensitive issue that
has long divided people into a kind of.
Speaker 1: Gosh, isn't this inspiring.
Speaker 4: A bidding war?
How many weeks are you for? How many
exceptions are you for? And the list goes on.
But these questions miss the point. If the
goal is about saving as many lives as possible,
you don't save any lives if you can't enact your
position into law. And you can't do that unless
you find consensus. Reaching consensus. Starts
with humanizing, not demonizing. Just like I have
my story, I respect everyone who has their story.
I don't judge someone who is pro-choice any more
than I want them to judge me for being pro-life.
Speaker 1: So she says some things that are fine,
like let's not judge each other and try to find
consensus and have compassion and whatever else.
But this is just not moving the needle. And I'll
tell you where the polling is in a moment. But
just just a completely whatever the opposite of
an electrifying campaign would be. That's what
Nikki Haley seems to be running. She also
commented about how she feels when people
decide not to go through with a pregnancy.
Speaker 4: Michael and I struggle to have
children of our own. I had many challenges
as a teenager and in my college years. I went
through numerous surgeries when Michael and
I were married. I couldn't wait to be a mom.
But what happened so easily for many of my
friends was not my path. We went through
countless sessions of fertility treatments.
Every day I wake up and see or speak to my
two children. I feel blessed. The greatest
job I will ever have is being their mom.
Our eldest daughter got married just ten days
ago. I will never forget the day she was born
and then seeing her walk down the wedding.
Speaker 1: I don't know what it is about
these speeches that Nikki Haley gives. Like the.
These are nice, touching stories in some abstract
sense. Your daughter being born. Your daughter's
wedding day. Compassion, empathy. But I don't
know if it's like how the stories are written
for her and she reads. There's something about
this that couldn't possibly be less interesting.
Speaker 4: With her dad, I felt what countless
parents feel love, pride, overwhelming joy.
I believe every life is a blessing from God.
Speaker 1: You know.
Speaker 4: My heart hurts when someone
decides not to go through with a pregnancy.
Speaker 1: Okay, so in terms of how this is going,
it's hard to imagine Nikki Haley even making it
to the first primary. But I guess she's going to
stick around long enough to debate. If we look
at recent polling here, we have an Ipsos Reuters
poll where Haley is polling 3%. We have a morning
consult poll where Haley is polling 3%. We have a
big village poll where Haley is polling 6%. That's
a B-minus rated poll. So, you know, she's sort of
like 3%. Nikki, I guess, is where we are at this
point in time. So, listen, I don't take away
anything. From anybody's right and ability to run.
And her desire, I'm sure, I guess, is genuine. And
unless she's auditioning for VP in which it's
sort of like a publicity tour. But I do wonder
and I know I've said this before, and whenever I
mention it, people in my audience seem to not be
on the same page. I've asked before when someone
like Nikki Haley talks presumably to advisors and
her family and decides to run. Does she actually
think to herself, okay, let's see, I'm polling 3%.
Trump already has 53%. Here's my path to winning.
Like, does she actually think she could win?
Or is it more of a I think I could get
some positive attention if I do this,
even though I know I'm not going to win whenever
I bring this up, some people write to me and say,
No, David, People become like almost like
delusional and they think they could possibly
win. And other people write to me, no. Now,
David, of course you understand she can't win
and Chris Christie knows he can't win and Vivek
Ramaswamy knows he can't win, but they calculate
that it's worth running for some other reason.
I don't know the answer, but it's very difficult
to imagine how Nikki Haley could look at the
situation and think, I can win and I can win
by making quite literally the least interesting
speeches in the world about abortion to the Small
Business Association. It's crazy to me. Let me
know what you think. We're going to take a quick
break. We will hear from Ronna McDaniel after the
break. We'll talk about the Trump rape trial that
has started many, many other things to discuss.
Stay with us. We'll be back right after this.